depuis le 1er janvier les yvelinois
peuvent dissocier plus de 50 nuance de
gris dans le ciel aux quatre coins du
département
le soleil est porté disparu suite à une
perturbation venue des îles britanniques
et cela joue évidemment sur leur moral
les passes et les tropiques et et wi fi
c'est une déprime cc on est on est à la
fin là franchement on touche le bout en
bout de sens bien gris au total les
yvelinois l'ont vu le soleil que 3h58 au
14 janvier d'après un relevé de la
station météorologique de trappes un
phénomène rarissime les nuages devraient
prolonger leur séjour sur les îles dans
les prochaines semaines les températures
quand elles baisseront ce qui pourrait
entraîner quelques flocons dans le
département ce week-end ou en début de
semaine prochaine